Rồi các bạn ơi, hôm qua chúng ta đã cùng
nhau làm quen một chút với Docker đúng
không? Docker dùng để làm gì? Docker
dùng để đóng gói cái sản phẩm của chúng
ta. Sản phẩm nó có thể là một cái ứng
dụng, một cái trang web, một cái cái
project AI đúng không? Thế hôm qua chúng
ta cùng nhau chúng ta làm quen với cái
ví dụ chúng ta sử dụng à chúng ta chúng
ta chúng ta dùng cái ví dụ có sẵn đúng
không? cái ví dụ về Welcome to Docker để
chúng ta có thể chạy một cái trang web
mình mở lại nhá.
Mình mở lại cái Docker desktop nhá.
Đây Docker desktop chúng ta qua như thế
này đúng không? Nó giúp chúng ta có thể
làm việc với các cái docker chúng ta làm
việc chúng ta tạo chúng ta quản lý
Docker image docker container nó dễ hơn
đúng không? Mình à hôm qua chúng ta có
một cái docker image và chúng ta từ cái
docker image này chúng ta chạy được hai
cái docker container. Đ mình mình xóa đi
nhá. Mình xóa hai container này đi nhá.
Được chưa? Xóa đi. Được chưa? Docker
image mình đây. Được chưa? Hôm qua mình
tạo ra mình sẽ chạy lại này. À đây thì
nó đang a tắt và giờ mình chạy nhá. Đúng
không? Chạy mình có cái optional setting
này đúng không? Cái a cái docker
cái docker file cho định nghĩa ấy đúng
không? Chúng ta sẽ exp một cái cổng này.
Cổng này là cổng để cái web chúng ta nó
lắng nghe request đến từ người dùng đúng
không? Thì đây là cái cổng ở bên trong
container. chúng ta sẽ phải ánh xạ nó
đến một cái cổng vật lý trên máy của
chúng ta đúng không? Tại vì để cho các
cái request từ bên ngoài có thể nó chui
được vào trong cái đ container này. Được
chưa? Thì ví dụ là hôm qua mình lấy cái
ví dụ đầu tiên là mình sẽ dùng luôn cổng
3000 trên máy mình. Cổng 3000 trên máy
mình ví dụ là nó không vướng cái gì cả
thì chúng ta chúng ta dùng luôn được
chưa? Mình dùng luôn như này. Thế cái
tên của thếer các bạn đặt thì cũng được
không đặt chả sao. Không đặt thì Docker
desktop này tự động nó gen cho các bạn
được chưa? Nó cơ
đúng rồi. Nó chạy đến máy của chúng ta.
Nó chạy đến máy của chúng ta. Nó dùng
tài nguyên máy của mình. Nó dùng tài
nguyên máy của mình. Nó dùng CPU, nó
dùng RAM thậm chí nó dùng GPU của máy
của mình đấy chứ không đúng không? Nó
dùng trên máy của mình. Máy mình có cái
gì chúng cung cấp cho nó đúng không? Nó
sẽ là một cái môi trường nó được môi
trường riêng biệt với cái môi trường lập
trình của máy chúng ta nhưng mà nó dùng
tài nguyên chung. Tài nguyên chung RAM
rủng CPU các thứ dùng tài nguyên chung.
Máy các bạn càng khỏe chạy nó càng
nhanh. Được chưa? Đấy là mình run. Nó ăn
xong thì mình sẽ có một cái container
như này. Xong các bạn có thể mở trong
web ở đây. Trang web đây. Bom dân nh qu
này. Được chưa?
Đây là cái ví dụ chúng ta dùng cái ví dụ
có sẵn của Docker họ cung cấp đúng
không? Để chúng ta có thể chạy một trang
phép đơn giản đúng không? Người dùng họ
sẽ phải truy cập đến cổng 3000 trên máy
chúng ta. Cái cổng 3000 trên máy của
chúng ta ấy nó lại được kết nối đến cổng
3000 bên trong container. Đấy. Bên trong
container như thế này. Đấy. Bên trong
container như này được chưa? Đấy. Thì
chúng ta có thể truy cập đến cái tại vì
sao? Tại vì cái web nó được chạy ở trong
container đúng không? Cái web thực sự nó
chạy trong trong container. Chúng ta sẽ
phải vào đúng cái cổng 3000 của
container chúng ta mới mở ở trong web
này. Nhưng mà cổng 3000 của container
thì bình thường từ ngoài nó sẽ không thể
truy cập vào được. Chúng ta sẽ phải mở
cái ánh xạ cho ánh xạ cổng 3000 trên máy
của chúng ta đến cổng 3000 trong
container thì sau này đây do kiểu là cái
cái cầu đấy. Cái cầu kết nối giữa hai
bên đấy đúng không?
Đây cho chưa dùng có sẵn. Thì hôm nay
chúng ta mình xóa đi nhá. Xóa đi nhá.
Dùng xong biết thế thôi đúng không? Mình
xóa đi, mình xóa cả image này luôn. Xóa
đi, cũng coi như là mới tinh chả có cái
gì cả. Được chưa? Mới tinh đúng không?
Locker containers trắng tinh này. Images
trắng tinh. Được chưa? Thì hôm nay chúng
ta sẽ cùng nhau chúng ta tự mình chúng
ta tạo ra một cái docker image của riêng
chúng ta. Chúng ta sẽ từ cái docker
image này chúng ta sẽ chạy cái container
của riêng chúng ta. Được chưa?
Thế thì bây giờ mình sẽ để cho nó dễ đi
mình sẽ xóa bớt cái thứ linh linh tinh
đi nhá. Ví dụ một cái producter mình xóa
đi được chưa? xóa đi không cần nữa được
chưa tráng tinh này. Thế bây giờ đi giả
sử mình sẽ làm luôn với cái
với cái script classification này đúng
không? Đây là cái script đây là cái
project đầu tiên chúng ta trong cả cái
khóa này đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ được
cái mô hình phân loại dành cho cái bộ
diabet đấy đúng không? Ờ đây là mình
chạy trên máy của mình đúng không? Cái
lốp bình thường lúc chúng ta học là
chúng ta chạy trên máy của chúng ta chạy
như này đúng không? Chúng ta cài các cái
thư viện trên máy chúng ta chạy nó trên
máy luôn đúng không? Chúng ta có Pandas,
chúng ta có cơn chúng ta dùng thư viện
Lazy Predict các thứ này, rồi Profiling
chúng ta dùng rất nhiều thứ như này.
Được chưa? Đây là lúc trước là chúng ta
chạy trên máy của chúng ta. Lần đầu chạy
nó hơi lâu một tí các bạn nhá. Thế bây
giờ chúng ta sẽ làm sao? Chúng ta sẽ tạo
ra một cái môi trường bên trong Docker
để chúng ta có thể chạy cái chạy cái
script này bên trong đấy đúng không?
Chúng ta sẽ tạo ra một cái môi trường nó
sẽ hoàn toàn nó cách nó tách biệt với
cái môi trường của chúng ta đúng không?
Sau này chúng ta muốn chạy trên máy của
người khác, chúng ta bê nguyên ra chúng
ta chạy, chúng ta không cần phải cài thủ
công nữa. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ để làm
được điều đấy, chúng ta sẽ phải tạo ra
một cái docker file. Hôm qua chúng ta
các bạn thấy rồi đúng không? Chúng ta
phải có cái docker file đã được chưa?
Docker file các bạn có thể một các bạn
đây. Đây là mình cài cái add on của nó
rồi nó có luôn. Còn không các bạn phải
tạo một cái file nhá. Các bạn đặt tên nó
là docker file được đúng không? Docker
file. Cái file này có điểm đặc biệt là
gì? Nó không có phần mở rộng. Được chưa?
File này nó không có phần mở rộng. Phần
mở rộng gì? Tức là
chpdf.tex.csv.mp3.mp4.
MV4 đấy là phần mở rộng. Đây là chúng ta
không có phần mở rộng. Được chưa? Enter.
Một cái này. Mình cài cái add on của nó
rồi nên là các bạn thấy luôn nó có cái
hình là con con cá voi trên có cái thùng
hàng này. Được chưa? Còn các bạn chưa
cài có thể các bạn sẽ không có nhưng mà
không không có vấn đề gì. Có hay không
thì cũng không vấn đề gì. Cho nên c bình
thường thôi.
Thế thì à
đầu tiên như hôm qua mình nói ấy là gì?
là cũng giống như kiểu trong lập trình
hướng đối tượng ấy. Ờ chúng ta thường
khi chúng ta thiết kế một cái chúng ta
thiết kế một cái
docker image này chúng ta sẽ gần như trả
bờ câu chuyện chúng ta thiết kế từ đầu
và chúng ta sẽ kế thừa nó từ một cái
docker image nào đó mà một ai đấy người
ta đã thiết kế rồi đúng không? Chúng ta
sẽ chỉ chúng ta ờ tận dụng cái họ đã
thiết kế. Chúng ta chỉ mở rộng thêm
những cái gì chúng ta cần thôi. Được
chưa? Thế thì [khịt mũi] bây giờ ví dụ
đi. Ví dụ là bây giờ mình muốn máy mình
thì mình chạy Windows rồi thì rõ rồi
được không? Máy mình chạy Windows nhưng
bây giờ mình muốn tạo ra một cái môi
trường nó sử dụng hệ điều hành khác. Ví
dụ mình muốn nó sử hệ điều hành Ubuntu
chẳng hạn đúng không? Mình muốn dùng cái
nhân Linux đúng không? Sa mình muốn hệ
đánh Linux mình dùng Ubuntu chẳng hạn
được chưa? Máy mình chạy Windows nhưng
mình hoàn toàn mình có thể tạo một cái
môi trường chạy Ubuntu chả có vấn đề gì
cả. Được chưa? Sau này cái máy mà các
bạn triển khai cho khách ấy, máy họ có
dùng Windows hay là Ma cũng không quan
trọng. Tại vì là kể cả máy họ có chạy
chạy ma đi nữa ấy thì khi mà các bạn lôi
cái docker image này các bạn chạy để các
bạn tạo ra container chạy trên máy của
họ ấy thì nó cũng sẽ tạo ra một cái môi
trường dùng umundu đúng không các bạn?
Thiết kế nó chạy ở môi trường nào nó
chạy đúng cái môi trường đấy. Được chưa?
Thì thông thường khi mà các bạn đóng sản
phẩm, các bạn dùng cái hệ điều hành trên
Linux ví dụ như là Ubuntu, Redhead chẳng
hạn hoặc là CentOS chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ
thường người ta hay dùng cái hệ điều
hành này hệ đánh mã nguồn mở. Được chưa?
Thế thì bây giờ mình muốn mình muốn tạo
ra một cái môi trường un thì mình phải
xem là có cái docker image nào mà nó tạo
ra để dừng dành cho dành cho U2 sẵn rồi.
Thế bây mình lại vào sang Docker Hub hôm
qua được chưa nhá.
Locker hub này. Locker hub nhá. Được
chưa? và hub này. Thế bây giờ như mình
vừa nói mình muốn tạo mình muốn là cái
docker container xong mình tạo ra ấ nó
chạy untu thì mình sẽ search ở đây mình
gõ um này untu enter được chưa? Nhìn qua
những cái tên ở đây hôm qua mình nói các
bạn rồi nó có một vài những cái tag như
này đúng không? Thông thường ông nào mà
càng official nó càng ấy nó càng dùng
nhiều nó sẽ đẩy lên đầu các bạn đóng
docker official image này được chưa?
Docker official image đúng không? Đấy nó
có nhiều phiên bản nhưng mà đây mình
thấy có cái ông
official luôn thì mình dùng luôn thôi.
Untu này. Click vào đây được chưa? Click
vào đây thì các bạn thấy là tên của cái
doc image này nó cũng là Umuntu luôn.
Bản official cũng tên Umuntu luôn được
chưa? Umuntu. Thế nhưng mà lớp mình có b
nào bạn đã từng dùng umon rồi các bạn
cho mình cho mình số 1 được không? Lớp
mình có bạn nào từng dùng umon rồi cho
mình số 1 được không? Bạn nào chưa dùng
bao giờ cho mình số 0. Để mình xem là
lớp mình có bạn nào biết cái hệ điều
hành và hành này nó là hệ đội bành gì
không.
Ok
bạn ba bạn biết ba bạn bốn bạn không
biết bình thường các bạn dùng Windows
đúng không? Lớp mình không biết các bạn
dùng Windows đúng không? Windows là cái
hệ đ hành nó sẽ phù hợp với cho ví dụ là
thường là cho end user tức là người dùng
cuối chúng ta ấy thì nó sẽ ok. Còn khi
mà các bạn muốn xây dựng sản phẩm xựng
ứng dụng ấy thì thông thường thông
thường thì các cái hệ đường mãng nguồn
mở ví dụ như là U2 chẳng ạ nó sẽ phù hợp
hơn thì các bạn sẽ quản lý các cái gói
các bạn quản lý môi trường nó sẽ dễ dàng
hơn. Cài đặt nó cũng sẽ dễ dàng hơn.
Bình thường các bạn cài trên Windows các
bạn thấy là các bạn cứ tải cái file về
các bạn cứ next next next đúng không?
Thế nhưng mà thật ra các bạn chùm chụ un
các bạn sẽ cài qua terminal nó sẽ
có thể lúc mới đầu các bạn không quen
các bạn thấy nó hơi lằng nhằng nhưng mà
thực ra các bạn quen rồi các bạn thấy
rất là thích luôn cài qua th cài các cái
package qua terminal cực kỳ thích luôn
không phải thích là chỉ việc các bạn
nhìn thấy giống như kiểu hacker đâu mà
thực sự cài nó sẽ dễ dàng hơn rất là
nhiều
thì bây giờ mình sẽ mình nhìn qua nhá
cái ung t này thì bây giờ mình sẽ cái
tag của nó có những phiên bản gì unto nó
có nhiều phiên bản lắm ví dụ các bạn
nhìn nhá phiên bản ví dụ như là nó có
phiên bản mới phiên bản không hẳn là mớ
Thứ nhất, mới nhất nó bây giờ nó có bản
25 rồi. Các bạn có cái tạ bản 24.04 này
đúng không? Rồi các bạn có 22.04
các bạn có 20.04 th phi bản nó cứ nhảy
hai phiên bản 20.04 đây có 26.04 này.
Đấy chưa ờ nhiều lắm
rất nhiều phiên bản có những phiên bản
tên mình cũng nhìn qua tên mình cũng
không luận ra nó là cái gì. 20 rồi 18
các thứ nhiều lắm. Được chưa? Thì bây
giờ mình sẽ lấy lấy thử một cái đi. Ờ 24
thì cũng chả phải bản mới nhất nhưng mà
thôi mình cứ dùng thử đi. Dùng thử đi.
Được chưa? Nó như thế này.
Đây th bản đây. Được chưa? Ờ các bạn
muốn lấy nó về thì câu lệnh đâu rồi?
Đâu ấy nhỉ?
Đây các bạn lấy cái đây. Được chưa? Các
bạn muốn lấy nó về, các bạn muốn tải nó
về thì các bạn dùng docker pool các thứ
này đúng không? to hai thế này. Một là
các bạn, các bạn muốn P là các bạn kéo
nó về đấy đúng không? Kéo nó về thì các
bạn sẽ mở cái terminal này ra.
Các bạn mở một cái terminal này ra được
chưa?
Một là các bạn full như này.
Các bạn chờ một tí nhá.
Các bạn chờ chút cái mình chạy lần đầu
nó hơi nó hơi mất thời gian một chút.
Đây nhá.
Một là các bạn p nó về như này, mình gõ
enter và nó sẽ tải về ngay. Được chưa?
Hiện nay trên máy mình thì nó chưa có
cái hiện nay máy mình mình chả có cái
docker image nào cả. Máy mình không có
đâ đ image trắng tinh chẳng có cái gì
này. Được chưa? Hoặc các bạn có thể đõ
là
image này chả có cái gì cả này đúng
không? Trắng tinh chả có cái gì. Bây giờ
mà mình mà pull cái này về ấy thì lập
tức là nó sẽ có một cái mô hình ở trong
ở ngay. Một là các bạn full này cũng
được. Hai là các bạn có thể bây giờ các
bạn đây nhá. Ví dụ mình nhá nó mình p về
nhá. Enter này được chưa? Lần đầu chạy
thì nó sẽ nó sẽ phải tải cái docker
image này từ trên docker hub về. Đây nó
đang tải về này. Tải về này. Đấy tải về
đấy. Được chưa? Tải về xong rồi các bạn
nhìn này. Các bạn nhìn thấy chưa? Mình
có một cái rồi đúng không? Docker tên là
Umuntu. Được chưa? Tag là 24.04. Được
chưa? Đây là nó được tạo ra 10 năm à 25
ngày trước được chưa? Cái image ID nó
dướ cửa cái căn cứ công dân ấy. Được
chưa? Các bạn hoàn toàn các bạn có thể
có hai cái doer image tên giống nhau
nhưng mà cái image ID nó sẽ khác nhau.
Tại vì tên ví dụ là hai ông cũng tên là
Việt chẳng hạn nhưng mà căn cứ công dân
nó sẽ khác nhau đúng không? Đấy.
Thế thì bây giờ mình có cái
mình có cái docker image này rồi. Bây gi
bây gi báo là bây giờ mình muốn là cái
docker image mình nó sẽ kế thừa từ cái
docker từ cái image mà mình vừa mới p về
mình sẽ kế thừa như này. From được chưa?
Form U2.22.
22 là 24 ấ nhở. 24 đúng không? 24.04.
Được chưa? Đây chư là cách để chỉ ra là
cái docker image của mình nó sẽ kế thừa
từ cái
docker image 24.04 được xây dựng sẵn
này.
Thì bây giờ có cái này rồi các bạn kế
thường rồi thì các bạn hoàn toàn các bạn
có thể các bạn bu cái docker image của
riêng các bạn. Tất nhiên là hiện tại cái
docker image của chúng ta nó chả khác gì
cái docker image cha này cả. Bây giờ ông
con ông cha chả khác gì nhau. Tại vì các
bạn mới chỉ có đúng kế thừa thôi. Mới kế
thừa các bạn chưa mở rộng chưa modify
cái gì cả thì hai cái ông nó giống như
yệt nhau. Ông con ông cha giống như yệt
nhau. Thì bây giờ cứ thử chúng ta cứ tạo
ra nhá. Được chưa? muốn tạo ra hôm qua
chúng ta xem rồi ví dụ này cách này bui
này được chưa trừ tên của cái image đó
tên các bạn muốn đặt tên gì cũng được
mình thích mình đặt tên là viền Nguyễn
AI cũng được nhưng mà thường các bạn đặt
cái tên nào để nghe nó gợi nhớ à không
phải thế là các bạn nghe các bạn nhìn
các bạn biết là nó về cái gì ví dụ đây
mình đặt tên là ML machin được chưa cách
chấm này chấm tức là gì chấm tức là tôi
sẽ bọi thứ từ cái thư mục gốc hiện tạ
tôi cũng sẽ tìm tìm cái docker file của
tôi trong cái thư mục gốc hiện tại. Thư
mục gốc mình nó là cái thư mục machining
này này. Thư mục gốc này thì trong
machining nó có cái file docker file ở
đây đúng không? Lại tìm từ đây rồi nó
sau này có cái cái file khác nọ cũng tìm
từ thư mục gốc này. Được chưa? Docker
này cách bui là tôi đang bui một cái
docker image mới của tôi. Được chưa?
Ờ không em ạ không mình cứ tập trung cái
này đã nhá. Tập trung với cái này đã
được chưa nhá. Docker này cách bui này.
Trừ t này. Cách ml này. Chấm một cái này
được chưa? Mình enter một cái là mình sẽ
bom cái doc image của riêng mình. Hiện
tại nó mới chỉ nó kế thừa tướng này
thôi. Tức là nó giống y chang đấy. Được
chưa? Nhìn nhá. Enter một cái này.
Rất là nhanh. Tại vì sao? Tại vì là
nguyên liệu có hết rồi. Nó chứa đúng một
bước thôi. Một bước thôi. Thông thường
bước này nó sẽ rất là lâu. Thế nhưng mà
tại vì tôi đã p nó từ trước rồi nên là
nó mới nhanh. Bây giờ các bạn nhìn nhá.
Bây giờ giả sử nhá. Bây giờ mình bây giờ
mình mình tạo ra một cái document của
mình này. Được chưa? Đấy. Có vẻ là các
bạn thấy không? Kích thước nó khác gì
đúng không? Kích thước nó nó nó khác một
chút xíu. Nó khác một chút xíu nhưng mà
vậy mà nội dung nó chả khác gì cả. Bây
giờ giả sử nhá, bây giờ mình xóa cả hai
ông này đi nhá. Mình xóa cả hai ông. Bây
giờ các bạn thấy không? Cái do cái
Ubuntu này là cái vẫn mình pull từ nãy.
Đây là cái mình vừa mới búng không các
bạn? Pull docker image về nó cũng trong
nó cũng nằm trong cái danh sách này mà
các bạn các bạn tự xây dựng một cái
docker image của bạn nó cũng nằm trong
danh sách này. Giả sử bây gi hết nhá.
Mình xóa đi hết này. Xóa cả hai ông đi
chả có cái gì cả nữa. Được chưa? Thế bây
giờ xem lại ở đây nhá. Docker này images
này. Một là các bạn xem danh sách cái
docker image ở đây. Hai các bạn dùng cái
lệnh docker images enter. Em chả có cái
gì cả. Được chưa? Bây giờ mình mà mình
mà b nhá, mình bôi lại nhá. Thì bây giờ
trước đấy mình chưa có p do image này về
nhưng mà khi mình bôi này về nó sẽ tự
động nó p về. Được chưa? Nhìn này. Enter
này. Đấy b này. Đấy nó bề đấy. Nó nó nó
bắt đầu nó tải về. Đấy thấy chưa này.
Kết này. Tại vì mình trước mình đã lưu
một lần rồi.
Xem lại cái đây nhá. Được chưa? Các bạn
thấy là chúng ta có chúng ta có cái
docker image chúng ta chúng ta tự xây
dựng đấy đúng không? Hiện tại thì nó
giống nó giống y trang với cái image
đúng không? Mà tiễn mình sẽ mở rộng sau.
Thế đây là mình đang mình đang vui một
cái docker image rồi. Và khi mình có cái
docker image này rồi mình có thể tạo ra
được vô số container từ cái image này.
Vô số container. Thì bây giờ mình muốn
mình muốn tạo ra một cái container thì
mình làm thế nào? Thì các bạn nhìn nhá.
Bây giờ mình muốn tạo ra container thì
sẽ như này. Docker này, run này. Được
chưa?
Rồi tên của cái docker image là ML
được chưa?
Thế thôi. Docker run ML xong. Docker này
là từ khóa run là thôi tạo ra một
container đúng không? Enter này.
Enter
nó tạo ra rồi nó xóa luôn. Nó xóa luôn.
Đây này. Nó vừa tạo ra nó xóa luôn. À
không phải xư bạn không phải nó xóa luôn
mà nó dừng luôn. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
chúng ta cũng chả có cái gì trong này cả
nhá. Mình chạy một lần nữa nhá các bạn.
Nh đang có một cái container là mình vừa
tạo ra đúng không? Tên nó tự tạo ra này.
Chạy một lần nữa nhá.
Xong hai cái rồi. Tiếp này. 3 này. 4
này. 5 này. Được chưa? Mỗi lần chúng ta
chạy ấ nó lại tạo ra một cái docker
container này. Nhưng mà các bạn nhìn cái
dấu ở đây này. Đây là assisted đúng
không? Docker image thì đây là inuse tức
là gì? Tôi đang dùng nó đúng không? Doc
image là inuse nhưng mà container thì nó
exit. Tại vì sao các bạn vừa chạy cái là
nó tắt luôn. Đây mình cho các bạn xem
nhìn nhá. Nó sẽ rất là nhanh các bạn.
Các bạn phải nhìn rất là nhanh nhá. Nhìn
này. Mình chạy này. Các bạn thấy nó sẽ
tạo ra một cái mới. Nó sẽ có cái đầu
tiên nó có cái màu xanh xong nó sẽ tức
là màu xanh ta inu sau đó nó lại tắt
luôn rất là nhanh. Nhìn nhá. Nhìn này.
Đấy các bạn thấy không? Nó tạo ra cái
mới nó tắt rất là nhanh luôn. Nhìn nhá.
Đấy được chưa? Tắt rất là nhanh. Nó tắt
tại vì là tại vì là mình đang không có
cái chỉ thị gì cho nó cả. Mình chỉ nói
là mình kế thừa thôi. Nó kế thừa xong là
hết. Nó dừng luôn. Được chưa?
Thế thì bây giờ ấy giờ mình lại xóa bớt
đi nhá. Xóa xóa xóa chỗ này đi. Xóa đi.
Được chưa? Thế bây giờ mình mình muốn là
gì? Tại vì mình biết là cái container
của mình ấy nó sẽ là một cái môi trường
nó hoàn toàn là nó nó tách biệt với cái
môi trường trên máy của chúng ta. Ví dụ
đây là mình đang môi trường này mình
đang chạy trong một cái environment tên
là RAC chẳng hạn đúng không? Tại vì mình
dùng cái môi trường này để mình làm ra
chatbot. Thế thì bây giờ mình muốn là
bây giờ mình muốn là khi mình tạo ra
container này ấ nó sẽ cho phép mình là
tương tác cái container đấy. Tương tác
có nghĩa gì? Tức là bây giờ mình muốn là
mình sẽ mình sẽ chui vào bên trong của
cái container được chưa? Mình muốn chui
vào bên trong của container để mình xem
là bên trong nó nó có cái gì chứ mình
không muốn là nó chạy phát tắt luôn.
Được chưa? Mình muốn là chui vào bên
trong nó. Chui vào bên trong thì làm thế
nào? Các bạn nhìn đây vẫn locker run
này. Thế nhưng mà trước cái chỗ tên
nàyer run này mình sẽ thêm một nữa là
trừ
được chưa? Trừ it trừ it này được chưa?
Xong mình sẽ đêm cái đuôi cuối là bass
này. Được chưa? Docker này, cách run
này, cách chữ ID như là cái bass này bây
giờ cũng không cần nữa thì phải enter
nào. Đúng rồi.
[âm nhạc]
Các bạn chờ một chút nhá.
Đây nhá. Bây giờ bây giờ cũng không cần
không cần cái không cần cái bass kia nữa
các bạn nhá. Bây giờ mình sẽ câu lệnh là
gì? Là Docker run này trước cái tên của
cái docker image của mình. Docker image
mình tên tên của nó là tên của nó đâu
rồi?
Tên của nó đây nó tên nó là ML V
machining đấy. Được chưa? Mình có thêm
cái trừ IT này. Trừ IT này nó sẽ cho
mình vào trong cái gọi là interactive
mode tức là cái mode để tương tác. Tức
là các bạn sắp phép các bạn là nhảy vào
bên trong container xem nó có cái gì.
Nhìn nhá. Hiện tại này mình đang ở trên
máy của mình được chưa? Mình đang ở ổ C
thư mục user Việt P project Machining
đây chính là cái thư mục của mình đây
này. Đấy trong này được chưa? C user
Việt P này. Được chưa? Mình chạy cái
lệnh này một cái. Các bạn nhìn nhá. chạy
một cái này. Enter này. Enter xong các
bạn nhìn này. Bây giờ ấy mình đang không
ở trong máy của mình nữa mà mình đã chui
vào bên trong của cái container rồi. Các
bạn nhìn nó khác chưa? Đây là kiệu của
trong này đúng không? Đây là tên của đây
là user này. User mình là root đúng
không? Tức là quyền nó là admin đấy.
Được chưa? Account. Sau đó là cái đây là
cái ID của container các bạn nhìn nhá.
Các nhng cái chuỗi ID này. Đây chính là
cái định danh của cái container 93 đuôi
là D18 nhá các bạn. Mở lại đây này. Nhìn
này các bạn nhìn nhá. Container của mình
các bạn thấy chưa? Bây giờ ấy cái name
nó vẫn là name nó tự sinh ra. Các bạn
nhìn cái ID của container này đúng
không? Đuôi này đây. 9302. Đấy được
chưa? Đây này. Thấy chưa? Đây này. Đấy
9302 các thứ này này. Đấy thấy chưa?
Thấy chưa? Và bây giờ cái dấu nó là gì?
Nó là running. Running tức là gì? Tức là
bây giờ bây giờ cái coner nó đang được
chạy chứ nó không phải là nó chạy xong
nó tắt luôn đúng không? Nó đang được
chạy. Chúng ta có thể chúng ta tương tác
với nó.
Được chưa? Nó đang chạy đấy. Đúng không?
Đây giống cái image này đúng không? Tôi
đang sử dụng nó. Còn về container nào
tôi đang chạy. Được chưa? Còn nếu bây
giờ ấy mình thoát ra khỏi cái container
này mình Ctrl D nhá. Ctrl D để thoát ra
Ctrl D một cái này. Exit. Lập tức các
bạn nhìn này. Cái màu nó thành cái này
thành màu trắng rồi. Exit là tôi thoát
ra rồi. Được chưa? Tôi thoát ra rồi. Đấy
được chưa? Thế cái trừ IT này nó giúp
mình sẽ chui vào bên trong đó. Mình lại
chạm lần nữa nhá. Sẽ tạo ra một ống mới
được chưa? Ống mới này đúng không? ID nó
đuôi là 093A này. Đây 090A đây. Đấy được
chưa? Đấy thấy chưa? Thế bây giờ mình sẽ
bây giờ mình đang ở bên trong này rồi.
Mình xem bên trong nó có có nó có cái gì
được chưa? Mình dùng lệnh LS này. LS
đây. Bạn nào các bạn từng dùng umu rồi
các bạn không còn xa lạ gì với cái thư
mục này đúng không? Ví dụ trong máy
chúng ta chúng ta dùng Windows chúng ta
sẽ có ổ C, ổ D, ổ F cái gì đấy thì trong
đây là những cái thư mục gốc của nó. Đây
thư mục root đấy. Đúng chưa?
PWD là cái
chúng ta đang ở cái thư mục gốc này.
Root này. Root cái root này nó khác cái
root này nhá. Đây là đây là tên của cái
tài khoản. Tài khoản root tứ là tài
khoản admin đấy. Còn đây là chúng ta
đang ở gốc cái project của chúng ta. Nó
có cái thư viện này. Đấy nó cái cái thư
mục chị chính xác hơn. Thư mục đúng
không? Thư mục này. Đấy được chưa? Đây
là chúng ta đang ở bên trong của cái
container. Mình mở một cái mình đã dùng
bình mở một cái terminal mới nhá. Mở cái
terminal mới này thì nó lại đang ở trong
máy của mình được chưa? Máy mình đây các
bạn chờ đây nhá. Đây là mình đang ở bên
trong của S đi nhá. Mình đang ở bên
trong của container còn đây là mình đang
ở trên máy của mình. Máy mình thì có
Python. Máy mình có Python mình có
Python 3. Được chưa? Máy mình
đây. Máy đâu không? Máy mình có Python
cụ thể là Python 3.11.13.
Đây là máy của mình đúng không? Đây mình
đang ở trong máy của mình này. Ổ C máy
của mình được chưa?
Nhưng mà cái môi trường ở bên trong
container là một cái môi trường nó hoàn
toàn nó tách biệt. Nó chỉ dụng chung
phần cứng thôi. Còn các cái thư viện cái
môi trường nó là hoàn toàn tách biệt.
Mình gọi Python nhá. Python này chả có
cái gì cả. Python Python 3 chả có cái gì
đúng không? Không có cái gì hết đúng
không? Tại vì đây là môi trường trong
máy của mình. Máy mình có cài Python
rồi. Còn trong container là nó chưa có.
Được chưa?
Cái môi trường này nó hoàn toàn nó tách
biệt. nó là nó isolate với cái môi
trường chính của máy của bạn. Thế nên ấy
nếu các bạn muốn thử nghiệm cái gì mà
các bạn sợ hỏng máy, các bạn cứ thử
nghiệm trong container. Các bạn muốn cài
muốn cắm, muốn xóa, muốn làm gì, các bạn
muốn làm gì các bạn cứ làm trong này.
Sau này nó có hỏng ấy các bạn xóa
container đi. Th các bạn exit ra ngoài,
xóa đi là xong, không ảnh hưởng gì đến
hòa bình thế giới cả đúng không? Muốn
thử nghiệm, muốn experiment gì cứ chui
vào trong container mà các bạn làm. Được
chưa? Tất nhiên nó còn nhiều cách khác
nữa. Thế nhưng mà đây là một cách đúng
không?
Thế thế bây giờ đây là một cái môi
trường fresh, một cái môi trường mới
tinh, trắng tinh, nó chả có cái gì cả.
Máy của mình mình cài nhiều thứ rồi.
Mình cài đủ các loại thư viện rồi. Mình
cài mình cài pandas, mình cài 5 P, mình
cài Map Public, mình cài đủ mọi thư viện
rồi. Đây này, mình cài N
trong cái môi trường này đến Python còn
chả có chứ còn những thứ việc kia đúng
không?
Tất nhiên tất nhiên chúng ta thật ra ấy
chúng ta cái lúc mà chúng ta chúng ta
tìm docker image ấ chúng ta tìm cái base
docker image ấy chúng ta hoàn toàn chúng
ta có khả năng chúng ta tìm luôn cái
docker image nó có sẵn python rồi nó có
sẵn rồi ví dụ mình thử tìm thử nhá
đây này mình có thể tìm cái doer image
mà nó có sẵn python rồi cho nó nhàn được
không lấy cái ông này thì các bạn cài về
phát là nó có sẵn python đây là có sẵn
pyon 3.13 3 rồi các bạn chả phải làm cái
gì cả. Được chưa? Nhưng ở đây tại vì
chúng ta đang practice, chúng ta đang
thử, chúng ta đang practice chúng ta tự
mình chúng ta tạo ra một cái docker
image tự xây dựng từ đầu đúng không? Nên
là mình chọn cho bạn một cái một cái
docker image mà nó chả có cái gì ngoài u
được không? Còn tất nhiên sau này các
bạn sẽ dùng cái ông nào nó tiện nhất. Ví
dụ mình làm về deep learning mình sẽ cần
sử dụng pch chẳng hạn. Mình hãy xem là
có cái môi trường nào nó quay sẵn p cho
mình rồi thì mình đỡ phải cài đâ. Cái gì
n mình tìm được cái do nó càng đầy đủ
thì mình càng ít phải add những cái mới
vào được chưa?
Thì bây giờ trong cái môi trường ở bên
trong container này của mình ấy nó hoàn
toàn nó chưa có Python thì mình muốn sử
dụng Python thì mình phải cài đúng
không? Mình phải cài Python được chưa?
Muốn cài các bạn chú ý này, các bạn đang
ở trong môi trường của U2 chứ không phải
trong môi trường của Windows nên các bạn
muốn cài cắm cái gì ấ các bạn sẽ phải
dùng đúng cái cú pháp của U2 chứ bạn
không cài trên Windows được. Trong
Windows bạn có thể các bạn có một cái
file SE các bạn click vào click đúp vào
các bạn next hoặc các bạn cài kiểu gì
đấy nhưng nó không làm như vậy được
chưa? Thì bây giờ giả sử bây giõ thôi.
Thật ra tại ta bác các bạn chatt thì các
bạn chả các bạn phải tự thiết kế cả.
Nhưng bây giờ chúng ta hãy coi như chúng
ta đang luyện tập chúng ta làm từ đầu
đúng không? Thì bây giờ nào install
Python
in to được chưa? Nó cho bạn nó cho bạn
cái câu lệnh đây các bạn nhìn này. Đ này
nó câu lệnh đây. Đấy đầu tiên các bạn
phải chạy một cái lệnh lệnh update
sudo để các bạn được chạy với cái quyền
admin. Nhưng mà khi mà các bạn đang ở
trong cái môi trường này, các bạn đang
trong ở trong cái content này, các bạn
đang ở cái vai trò là root rồi thì các
bạn auto là bạn các bạn có quyền admin
rồi. Các bạn không cần phải có cái sudo
này. Được chưa? Sudo nhá. Xong các bạn
có cái này các bạn có cái comment ở dưới
này được chưa? Python 3 full chưa? Hoặc
là các bạn cái Python 3 thôi cũng được.
Python 3 bình thường thôi cũng được chứ
không cần full. Tại mình mình cài nhiều
nên là mình biết còn không các bạn cứ
các bạn cứ có nguyên này cũng được chưa
các bạn cắp có nguyên mọi thứ cũng được
và mình dùng nhiều mình biết là các bạn
chỉn python là đủ rồi còn không các bạn
cho thêm cái đuôi full cũng không sao.
Thế nhưng mà đây là đây là cái hướng dẫn
nó mình phải dùng thử mới biết đúng
không? Tôi phải dùng thử tôi biết có
đúng hay không đúng không? App update
này được chưa? App update nhá. Mình nói
rồi các bạn có quyền sudo sẵn rồi. Các
bạn có quyền admin sẵn rồi. Các bạn
không cần phải thêm cái chỗ sudo nữa.
Các bạn chỉnh copy chỗ này thôi. Add
update nhá. Được chưa? Mình sẽ
chạy thử đã. Chạy thử đã được chưa? Face
này. App update này đúng không? Đây là
mình đang chạy ở bên trong của container
đấy đúng không? Chứ mình không chạy cho
máy của mình. Máy mình mình không không
chạy ở đâu tại vì là máy mình không phải
là um này app update này. Máy mình không
phải umun mình không chạy được câu lệnh
này. Đây câu lệnh của umu. Được chưa?
App mình chạy bên này thì được. Đây này
là um nhá. App update này. Enter này
được chưa? Đó là update. Đấy. Đấy các
bạn nhìn cái chữ unto to lù lùi chưa?
Được
chưa? Máy mình dùng Windows như mình
đang tạo ra một cái môi trường dùng unto
đấy. Xong rồi. Được chưa? Xong rồi. Xong
rồi. Thì bây giờ mình sẽ tiếp này nó nó
vào cái gì đây? App đây. Mình chỉ cài
đây thôi. Tại vì mình biết nó chỉ đến
đây thôi không các bạn. CN đây thôi.
Được chưa? App này install cái Python 3
này. Đúng không? Python 3 là cái gì? Thì
các cái phiên bản Python các bạn đang
dùng ấy đều là Python 3. Python 2 là cái
thời ngày xưa cái hồi mình học 2015 ấy,
hồi đấy nó có cái phiên bản Python 2.
Python 2 cú pháp nó khác một tí. Python
2 thì nó khác một chút về cú pháp. Ví dụ
câu lệnh print ngày xưa nhá. Ngày xưa về
Python 2 á các bạn có thể print như này
này.
Bây giờ bạn các bạn đang print kiểu này
đúng không? Ví dụ A B C thứ này đúng
không? Kiểu kiểu như này. Ngày xưa ấy về
Python 2 ấ các bạn không cần cái dấu
này.
Cái này là ok rồi. Nhưng mà Pon 3 nó
không cho phép như này. Được chưa?
Đấy. Thế bây giờ nó app install 3 nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này. Enter một cái này.
Enter này. Enter này.
Các bạn nhìn này. Nó sẽ có một cái dòng
như này. Đấy. Nó sẽ bảo là nó sẽ cài cái
gì đấy. Nó sẽ cài cái gì này. Đấy. Thấy
chưa? Tôi sẽ cài thêm cái packet gì này
đúng không? Rồi cái ông nào sẽ được cài
này đúng không? Đấy. Kiểu kiểu như vậy.
Nó hỏi là mày có muốn continue không?
Yes or no? Đúng không? Mình ấn yes này.
E này. Enter một cái này. Enter một cái
nhá. Thế nó cài nó cài nó cài thế này.
Rồi nó sẽ có cái câu hỏi các bạn chọn
cái vị trí các bạn điền cái gì cũng
được. Cái này các bạn không điền đúng
đâu. Mình mình chọn số 1 là Afric Châu
Phi nhá. Enter này chọn mình chọn bừa
một cái nước gì đấy mình chọn nốt số 9
đi biết sau được chưa? Muốn chọn cái gì
chọn không vấn đề. Bước này thì không
vấn đề. Xong rồi cài xong rồi. Được
chưa? Bây giờ mình thử xem máy mình có
Python chưa. Python này. Enter này.
Python thì không có tại vì mình cài
Python 3. Python 3 thì mới được.
3 đấy. Được chưa? Python 3.2.3 này. Được
chưa? Nó khác cái môi trường ở đây của
mình. Đây các bạn nhìn này.
Máy mình là dùng Python 3.11.13
nhưng mà cái container à nhưng mà cái
môi trường mình tạo ra ấy nó lại dùng
phiên bản là 3.12.3. Hai ông khác nhau
chả liên quan gì đến nhau. Hai ông chả
liên quan gìến nhau. Hai môi trường hoàn
toàn tách biệt ở hai nơi khác biệt nhau.
Hai ông này không biết gì về nhau luôn.
Được chưa? Đấy là cách để chúng ta có
thể chúng ta cài các cái thư viện cần
thiết ở trong container.
Thế nhưng ở đây các bạn chú ý một điều
là gì? Là từ nãy đến giờ ấy mình đang
cài cắm mọi thứ trong một cái container
cụ thể. Cụ thể đây là cái container này
này. Đấy đuôi là 09BA. Được chưa? Mình
nãy giờ mình đang mình đang tương tác
với container đuôi 09BA này. Đang tương
tác với ông này nên giây là mình cài
mình update mình cài pat 3 trong cái
container này.
Thế thì
nếu bây giờ các bạn tạo ra một cái
container mới từ cái docker image này
thì cái container mới này nó sẽ hoàn
toàn nó không có Python. Tại vì sao? Nên
là mình cài là mình cài cho cái
container cụ thể. Còn các cái container
anh em của nó hoàn toàn nó sẽ không có.
Được chưa? Ông này sẽ ông này sẽ không
có mà cái ông khác được tạo ra cũng sẽ
không có luôn. Đấy ví dụ nhá. Ví dụ đây
ông này vẫn đang chạy đúng không? Bây gi
mình mở một cái cửa sổ mới nhá. Được
chưa? Bây giờ mình sẽ tạo ra một cái
container mới. Nhìn nhá.
Mình tắt cái cửa sổ của máy mình đi nhá.
Được chưa? Bây giờ mình sẽ mình tạo một
container mà nhá. Docker này được chưa?
Run này. Trừ IT này. ML nhá. Trước đầu
tiên mình đang có hai cái ông cũ thì tắt
từ lâu rồi đúng không? Ông mới thì đang
chạy được chưa? Chúng ta ra một cái mới
nhá. Enter này. Đấy, ra một cái mới này.
Cái mới này nó có cái ID đuôi là AB2F
này. AB2F đây này. AB2F này. Đấy, được
chưa? Chạy thử này. Pần 3 chả có cái gì
cả đúng không? Mặc dù hai ông này mình
xóa cái ông cũ này đi nhá.
Mặc dù hai container này đều được tạo ra
từ chung một dole image
nhưng hai ông này nó sẽ phát triển hai
đứng độc lập nhau. Các bạn cài gì vào
cái ông này nó sẽ không ảnh hưởng gì đến
ông kia.
Các bạn cài cắm thư viện vào cái ông đầu
tiên này, ông thứ hai sẽ không được
hưởng và ngược lại. Các bạn xóa gì ở cái
ông đầu, ông thứ hai nó cũng bị ảnh
hưởng và ngược lại. Nếu chúng ta muốn là
gì? Chúng ta muốn là tất cả các cái
docker container được tạo ra từ docker
image này đều có những cái thư viện đấy
thì chúng ta sẽ phải chỉ ra ngay trong
cái docker file này. Tức là gì? Tôi sẽ
cài đặt ở cái level của docker image chứ
tôi không cài vào container cụ thể. Các
bạn cài vào container cụ thể thì chỉ
đúng container đấy được hưởng thôi.
Nhưng các bạn chỉ ra các bạn muốn cài gì
trong cái docker trong cái docker file
này rồi các bạn bage ấy thì sau này tất
cả mọi container được tạo ra từ image
đấy sẽ đều được hưởng với cái thư viện
đấy. Bạn hiểu không? Đấy, còn không bây
giờ các bạn cứ tạo ra cái container mới
thì ông mới nó chả được hưởng gì từ ông
cũ cả. Được chưa? Ông cũ thì các bạn cài
Python rồi, ông mới nó không được hưởng.
Đấy,
vừa rồi á mình chạy hai lệnh, một là
lệnh update và hai là lệnh install
Python 3 này. Hai lệnh đều chạy bình
thường, tức là mình thấy là nó ngon rồi
đúng không? Thì bây giờ mình muốn là
trong tương lai, mình muốn trong tương
lai, bây giờ mình trong tương lai mình
tạo ra những cái container mới ấy thì
chúng nó sẽ có sẵn python pyon 3 mình
không phải cài nữa thì mình làm thế nào
thì mình sẽ chỉ ra ở trên này. Tức là
bây giờ tôi khi mà tôi vui cái doc image
của tôi thay vì tôi chỉ có mỗi cái việc
là tôi kế thừa mặc định này, tôi sẽ chỉ
ra luôn là tôi sẽ cài những cái gì. Run
này. Được chưa? App này update. Câu lệnh
này vậy tôi confirm là tôi confirm là
chạy được rồi đúng không? Chạy ok rồi.
Đây là một lệnh này. Thứ hai là run này.
App này
install Python 3. Được chưa? Install
Python 3.
Đây này. Và các bạn nhớ là khi mà các
bạn cài ấy có đoạn mà nó hỏi yes với no
đúng không? Thì nếu mà các bạn muốn là
khi cài ấ nó trả lời là yes ấy, các bạn
thêm cái nữa là gì? Trừ y này. Trừ y t
là gì? Tại vì là lúc mà các bạn chạy từ
đây nó sẽ không có hiện ra. Đây là với
là mình mình ngồi cài công ở đây thì nó
sẽ hiện ra một cái bảng nó hỏi yes thế
no. Chứ còn khi mà các bạn tạo docker
này thì nó sẽ không có cái bảng đấy nó
hiện ra thì các bạn phải chỉ luôn là là
tôi sẽ chọn là yes đúng không? Trừ I
này. Được chưa? Đấy bây giờ mình thử
nhá. Bây gi thoát ra khỏi thoát ra khỏi
hai cái container này nhá. Tắt này một
ông tắt này. Hai ông tắt này. Được chưa?
Tắt cả hai ông đi. Tắt đi rồi thì các
bạn sẽ quay về đây. Các bạn thấy là đây
này. Hai ông bây giờ đấy. Exit rồi. Exit
rồi. Được chưa? Trong ông đầu tiên thì
có Python 3 nhưng trong ông thứ hai thì
không có. Được chưa? Bây gi mình xóa hết
mấy ông cũ này đi nhá. Xóa hết đi. Được
chưa? Xóa hết đi. Trắng tinh. Bây giờ
mình sẽ bây giờ là mình đã có một cái
cập nhật rồi. Lúc trước là mình chỉ có
đúng cái dòng đầu tiên thôi. Mình có
thêm hai cái dòng này nữa. Bây giờ mình
sẽ phải bùi mới. Bui mới đúng không các
bạn? Một khi các bạn thay đổi cái gì ở
docker file ấy mà các các bạn thay đổi
xong ấy các bạn sẽ cần phải bcker image
mới để nó nhận biết được những cái thứ
các bạn vừa thay đổi. Được chưa? Bui là
gì? Doctor
bui trừ t. T t t t tên vẫn tên cũ các
bạn đổi tên mới tôi tùy các bạn. Được
chưa? Docker bui trừ t ml là tên của cái
docker image đấy. Chấm là tôi sẽ tìm mọi
thứ tôi sẽ xuất phát từ cái thư mục hiện
tại. Được chưa?
Enter này. Thì bây giờ ấy khi mình enter
xong ấy cái dòng đầu tiên nó sẽ chạy nó
chạy rất là nhanh thôi. Tại vì mình
trong máy mình đã có sẵn rồi. Nhưng mà
hai cái dòng sau nó sẽ lâu hơn tại vì nó
sẽ cài sẽ phải cài đặt thư viện. Nhìn
nhá. Nhìn này. Enter này thì nó sẽ có ba
bước.
Bước đầu tiên thì là form này rất là
nhanh. Đấy. Bước đầu tiên rất là nhanh.
Nó có sẵn rồi. Bước thứ hai này nó c run
này các bạn. Bước một xong hết rồi. Nó
nó có trong bộ nh rồi. Bước thứ hai nó
run update này rồi run up in piton 3.
Đây nó cay các bạn không? Giống yên như
vậy các bạn nhìn thấy đúng không? Đây nó
chạy trong vừa là chúng ta chạy trong
terminal đây là trong bước cài này xong
hết rồi này. Được chưa? Nó tạo ra một
cái image mới. Thế thì bây giờ ấy các
bạn đã bu cái docker image mới này rồi
ấy thì sau này mọi docker container các
bạn tạo ra từ cái image này ấ chúng nó
sẽ có đầy đủ Python 3. Các bạn không
phải ngồi cài thủ công nữa. Thử nhá.
Nhìn này.
Run này nhá. Mình run này đúng không?
Mình tạo ra cái container nhá. Docker
run trừ it ml đúng không? Enter này. Gõ
thử này. Pon 3. Đẹp chưa? Bây giờ các
bạn tạo ra tất cả container từ document
này chúng ta sẽ đều có Python 3 sẵn luôn
không phải cài nữa. Được chưa không?
Rồi các bạn đến bước này có ai có câu
hỏi gì không?
Có cái gì chưa clear không?
Đến đây có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Clear đúng không? Hi vọng là các bạn vẫn
theo được nhá. Có cái gì không theo
được, cái gì chưa clear hỏi ngay nhá.
Được chưa? Rồi.
Mình có Python rồi. Thế nhưng mà bây giờ
ấy mình muốn chạy đạo script này thì
mình không chỉ cần Python mình cần nhiều
thứ khác. Mình cần pandas,
mình cần kilon,
mình cần picker, mình cần thư viện thậm
chí mình cần lazy predict đúng không?
Đây là mình chưa chạy tại vì mình không
dùng đấy, mình tắt nó đi rồi nhưng mà có
thể mình cần lazy PR đúng không? Mình
đang cần những cái thư viện này. Xem
mình có không nhá. Đúng không? Bây gi
mình phải kiểm tra xem là mình có không
nào. Import
pandas
không có. Pass không có được chưa?
Import escaler cũng không có luôn. Được
chưa? Mình chỉ mỗi Python thôi. Thử 5 P
đi. 5 P chắc phải có nhỉ? Import 5 P
5 P cũng không có. Đúng nó chỉ đúng và
chữ Python trắng phớ chả có cái gì cả
đúng không?
Picker chicker xem nào. Import picker à?
Picker thì lại có picker thì lại có được
chưa? Lazy pred thì khả năng cao cũng
không có rồi. Import lazy predict nhá
cũng không có luôn được chưa? Không có
rất nhiều thứ bên mình phải cài đúng
không? Mình mà không cài làm sao mình
chạy được cái đoạn này được chưa? Thì
cài như nào? Bây giờ lại ngồi lại ngồi
tìm thôi nào. Pandas cần pandas trước
đúng không? Gõ lại nhá. Import này
pandas là không có phải cài nó được
chưa? nó
nào
ờ
install andas các bạn vào trang chủ này
chứ
nhá xem cái phần đây install bandas này
được chưa
ờ
installation rồi installation page đâ
Đây
dùng pip thì cũng được nhưng mà nhưng mà
trong cái môi trường này thì nó chưa có
nó chưa có sẵn pip pip nó chưa có. Xem
có cái nào khác này không.
Ừ tải cũng được. Ừ đây tải. Ừ từ mình
đang xem có cái nào không phải tải
không. Các bạn dùng appg thì các bạn
không các bạn chú ý nhá trong Linux ấy
trong trong Linux nói chung trong nói
riêng ấy, các bạn tải một cái packit các
bạn sẽ có hai cách chọn. Các bạn sẽ có
hai cách dùng. Một là các bạn dùng app
app hoặc là app get như nhau. Hai là các
bạn dùng pit. Khác biệt là gì? App hay
là app get ấy là dùng để tải cái packet
chung chung. Nó không chỉ là của Python,
nó có thể pack cho JavaScript, packit
cho một cái gì đấy. Nó cài một cái một
cái công cụ gì đấy. Còn pip là để cài
riêng các cái thư viện dành cho Python.
Có những cái thư viện, có những cái
packet, có những cái thứ mà các bạn có
thể cài bằng cả upgate và cả pip. Ví dụ
như là skiller. Sit ler các bạn cài bằng
upg pip đưa tí v địa chỉ của các bạn.
Thế bây giờ ở đây mình không tận dụng
được upgate mình phải dùng pip thôi. Bây
giờ pip thì nó không có. Pip nó không có
đúng không? Comment not fil này. Bây giờ
phải mình phải cài pip trước. Được chưa?
pip này
to
install
pip như này được chưa nó hướng dẫn ra
đây nó an đây đúng không update vừa chạy
rồi đúng không app install pattern 3 pip
này đây cái mình cần đây cái mình cần
đây nhá update vẫ chạy rồi đây update vẫ
chạy rồi đây này update vẫn chạy chạy
rồi đây này update đây này chạy rồi được
chưa thế nhưng mà trước Khi mà các bạn
thêm một cái dòng ở cái do file này ấy
để cho chắc cú các bạn nên chạy thử
trong container. Đằng nào mình cũng mình
cũng đang mở container sẵn mà đúng
không? Đằng nào container nó mở sẵn có
mất cái gì đâu. Cài thử ở đây. Cài thử
trong container xem có ok không. Nếu
ngon lành thì tí nữa tôi thêm một dòng ở
trên này. Tôi thêm dòng ví dụ tôi thêm
này. Đấy thêm này là xong. Đây là với
điều kiện nó ngon lành. Còn nếu nó không
ngon lành thì mình phải xem là lỗi nó là
lỗi gì mình sửa đúng không? Cái nào ngon
rồi chạy thử container xong rồi mình mới
đưa lên trên này được chưa? App install
pattern 3 pip nhá. Enter nhá.
Nhìn này nó lại hỏng cái đoạn yes or no
này. Được chưa? Mình ấn yes nhá. Enter
này.
Hơi lâu ấy đúng không? Và các bạn chú ý
nhá, chúng ta cài như này ấy thì chỉ có
đúng cái container này nó được hưởng cái
package speed này thôi. Các cái
container khác nó không được hưởng đâu.
Tí nữa các bạn thoát ra khỏi đây rồi các
bạn mở ra một cái container mới là nó
lại trắng tinh từ đầu. Cài ok rồi đúng
không? Pip ok rồi. Bây giờ mình thử dùng
độ pip nhá. Pip này đấy được dùng rồi.
Dùng rồi đây này. Được chưa? C lệnh vễ
là ok rồi. An toàn rồi. Thêm vào đây run
này
có trừ y để nó ấn yes. Được chưa? Tại vì
các bạn mà không có cái chữ y này chạy
nó sẽ bị lỗi tại vì là nó có đoạn nó hỏi
chess no mà. Được chưa? Thế cài xong pip
rồi bây gi quay lại mình cài pandas.
Candas vẫy ở trên này nó hướng dẫn như
nào đây?
Pandas nhá. Đây đây con rồi. Pip này đây
nhìn mỗi này thôi được chưa? Mỗi này
thôi. Pip isopandas chạy thử đã đúng
không? Như mình nói rồi, bao giờ cũng
thế. Chạy thử trong container trước chạy
ok ngon thì mới copy paste lên trên.
Nhìn nhá.
Pip cách install, cách pandas nhá. Enter
này. Enter. Cái gì đây?
Đây.
Sao lại cái lỗi này nhỉ?
Rồi mở chat TPT nhanh ch nghĩ nhiều
này thôi
nhá.
À nó có option khác này. Cài qua app rồi
này.
Ok. Th dùng th cái app cho nó dễ nhá.
Được chưa? Cái app dễ nó có sẵn đây đúng
không? T vấn đề chả biết nữa thôi.
Nhưng mà mình phải thử ở đây. Thử ở đây
xem có vấn đề gì không. App install by
mất công cài pip nào. Enter này.
Đấy. Ok. Nh có vẻ ok này. Dùng app có vẻ
ok này.
Thế thì hiện tại mình chưa dùng đến cái
dòng pit này đúng không? Tạm thời mình
sẽ comment đi. Tôi sẽ chết rồi.
Tôi sẽ chưa xài nó. Chưa xài nó đâu. Tí
nữa mà xài đến tôi bật lại xong. Được
chưa? Tôi lại cài bằng app. Rồi
[hắng giọng]
app install bon 3 nhá. Được chưa?
Trông có vẻ ok đấy. Cà đây trông có vẻ
ok đấy.
Đúng không? Bao giờ cũng thế các bạn nhớ
nhá. Bao giờ cũng thế các bạn. Các bạn
chạy ở trong container trước. Ok rồi các
bạn hãy paste lên. Thật ra bây giờ sau
này các bạn dùng AI thôi, các bạn dùng
chat TV, các bạn dùng close để bạn nó
sinh ra thôi. Th bây giờ cái thời điểm
ngày nay sẽ chả ai người ta ngồi người
ta ngồi gõ từng dòng như này đâu. Nhưng
mà đây chúng ta đang practice để chúng
ta hiểu xem là cái cấu trúc nó như thế
nào nên chúng ta dùng từng dòng sau này
các bạn dùng close nó một phát là ra
ngay. Ấ mà nhá. Cài xong panas rồi mình
sẽ thử xem là Python 3 được chưa?
Pinport pandas. Ok rồi. Đẹp rồi. Xài
được đúng không? Xài được đúng chưa? Run
app inst này cách trừ y trừ y được chưa?
Trừ y có đoạn yes thì no. Đấy được chưa?
Mình có rồi.
Mình thiếu cái gì nhở? [hắng giọng]
Mình còn chưa có
mình chưa có picker có chưa nhỉ? Team
for picker. Picker thì có rồi. Size ken
thì chưa có đúng không? Sit ler nào
[hắng giọng] xem kit cài kiểu gì.
Sit learn nhá.
K chết rồi thừa đ chỗ này
đây.
Install
đây nó có cái pip này. Có pip ở đây.
Cài thử xem có vấn đề gì không. Cài thử
nhá.
Vẫn bị lỗi thôi thôi. Chắc là có cái lỗi
gì đấy với với pip rồi. Bỏ dòng pip đi
xem là có cái gì cài được với app không.
Cái xuống dưới này.
À đây đây đây. App ghép vệ app là như
nhau nhá.
Có Python s killer này. Mấy cái đây là
một cái thư viện phụ trợ cũng không cần
lắm đây mình cài thư viện này thôi. Được
chưa? App in sẽ trông cú pháp cũng na ná
đúng không? Đây cái pháp nó áo này mỗi
cái đuôi này sạch sẽ lơn thôi. Ba sạch
cái lơn này. À nhưng mà trước mình phải
mình phải mình phải chạy thử đã. Chạy
thử dưới xem có được không đã nhá.
[ho]
Chạy thử đã đúng không? Trông có vẻ ok
đấy. Được chưa? Trông vẻ ok
đấy. Có vẻ xong rồi. Thử xem nhá. Python
này. Pyon 3. Được chưa? Import escaler
này. Ngon lành. Ngon lành. Rồi được
chưa?
Mình còn cái thư viện thôi. Cái thư viện
Lazy BX này không dùng mình tắt lại đi
cho đơn giản nhá. Được chưa? Khi nào
dùng mình cài cài cũng tương tự như vậy
thôi. Được chưa? Thế ở đây các bạn nhìn
này. Bây giờ mình đang có các cái thư
viện mình có đang có Python 3 rồi đúng
không? Mình có Pandas, có rồi. Thế bây
giờ ấy ba ông này ấ thật ra là đều cài
theo cách tương tự nhau đều là app
install. Thì ra mình không cần phải đẻ
ra ba dòng, mình có thể gộp vào gộp vào
một dòng như này này. Viết nó cho một
dòng này. Ngăn cách bằng dấu phẩy à xin
lỗi bằng ngăn cách bằng khoảng trắng
này.
Đấy, được chưa? App này install 3, p sẽ
lên trừ y này. Được chưa? Cho nó gọn.
Còn không các bạn để ba dòng cũng chả
vấn đề gì.
[hắng giọng]
Thế bây giờ ấy mình có cái thay đổi này
rồi. Bây gi lại phải lại đi ra đúng
không? Mình bây giờ mình đang ở trong
container đúng không? Mình thoát này.
Thoát này. Ctrl D. Thoát ra đây. Mình
đang ở trong máy của mình. Được chưa?
Mình lại phải ngồi mình bại. Được chưa?
Lại ngồi bại. Đây lại b lại vì mình vừa
có update mà trước là mình chỉ có Python
3 thôi. Vì mình có cả Pandas, mình có cả
sơn rồi đúng không? Enter này nó lại
ngồi nó chạy lại. Được chưa?
Các bạn chú ý nhá. Một khi các bạn có
một cái thay đổi dướ ở cái docker file
này ấ mà các bạn bui lại ấy thì những
cái dòng trước chỗ thay đổi ấ nó sẽ
dùng cái bản cũ nó sẽ từ cái case này nó
sẽ rất là nhanh. Nhưng mà đây này đúng
không? Cái dòng đầu là cái dòng form có
sẵn rồi. Cái dòng thứ hai là cái dòng
update nó có sẵn như nó không có cái gì
mới cả. Nhưng mà từ cái dòng nó có cái
sự khác biệt này, lúc trước các bạn chỉ
có Python 3 thôi mà các bạn cài thêm cả
hai ông kia nữa thì nó sẽ chạy lại từ
cái dòng này và cả những dòng sau nữa.
Tức là ví dụ sau cái dòng này đi nó có
thêm mấy cái dòng mà nó vẫn giữ y trang
s bản cũ ấy thì nó cũng sẽ chạy lại. Đấy
là cái quy tắc để nó khi nó bui cơ image
mới. Thế nên ấy trong quá trình các bạn
xây dựng ấy có một cái mẹo là gì? Các
bạn muốn lúc nó vui lại nó vui nhanh ấy
thì những cái gì mới bạn thêm vào các
bạn thêm ở dưới cùng thì những cái dòng
ở trên nó không bị ảnh hưởng. Nó dùng
bản cũ luôn.
Các bạn chờ một tí nhá. Chờ nó nhạy thử
nhá.
Đấy. Thế bây giờ bây giờ mình có là gì?
Mình có Python 3 rồi, mình có FAS rồi,
mình có Sil rồi đúng không? Sau tí mình
sẽ thử xem mình chạy cái SP này như nào
nhá.
Trong lúc chờ có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì
không? Các bạn cứ hỏi nhá. Trong lúc chờ
bạn nào có thắc mắc gì bạn cứ hỏi nhá.
>> [ho]
[hắng giọng]
>> hơi lâu một tí
hình như nó xong rồi đấy. Nó hơi lag một
tí.
Đây chỗ này là gần xong rồi đấy.
Xong rồi. Xong rồi. Được chưa? Bui xong
rồi. Bu đã có image mới rồi. Up to date
rồi. Được chưa? Bây giờ run.
Run này.
Run này. Đây là môi trường ở bên trong
container đấy. Được chưa? It 3
import
được truyền được tí mình truyền. Tí mình
truyền cho các bạn xem. Tí mình truyền
cái tí mình truyền cái script python
này. Rồi các bạn muốn truyền gì vào bạn
tùy các bạn muốn truyền cái gì cũng
được. Import nhá. Import này. Pandas có.
Import skon cũng có. Ok chưa? Tức là về
mặt cái môi trường để chạy đạn script
thì là ok rồi
đúng không? Mặt môi trường chạy script
ok rồi. Thế nhưng mà bây giờ muốn chạy
các bạn phải có cái script này đã đúng
không? Scrip này nó đang ở trong máy của
bạn. Bây giờ các bạn phải copy nó vào
bên trong container thì nó thì mới chạy
được đúng không? Bây giờ lấy ra lấy cái
gì mà chạy đúng không? Chả có cái gì cả.
Chả có cái gì cả đúng không? Và các bạn
chú ý này, mặc định ấy khi mà các bạn đi
vào bên trong container nó sẽ ở cái root
này. Bây giờ các bạn muốn là nó sẽ vào
tức là tôi muốn là bây giờ tôi sẽ làm
mọi thứ trong một cái thư mục cụ thể thì
bạn có thêm một cái dòng như này. Các
bạn chú ý nhá. Ở đây mình thêm cái dòng
là work dear.
Mình ghi là Việt Nguyễn đi được chưa?
Việt Nguyễn như này mình c thêm đây từ
Nguyễn này. Thì bây giờ ấy sau này mà
khi các bạn nhảy vào container là mặc
định nó sẽ ở trong thư mục này luôn. Và
các bạn chú ý này, vừa giờ mình nói rồi,
bây giờ mình có một cái modify gì ở
trong cái docker file này ấy thì những
cái dòng trước cái chỗ modify ấy, trước
cái dòng trước cái chỗ modify ấ nó sẽ
giữ chạy, nó sẽ giữ nguyên, tức là nó sẽ
chạy từ cái kết lần trước. Nhưng mà
những dòng sau đấy nó sẽ chạy lại. Tức
là gì? Tức là kể cả bây giờ ấy khi mình
thêm cái dòng này vào đúng không? Hai
cái dòng ở phía sau này ấy trước đây
mình đã từng chạy rồi nhưng bây giờ nó
vẫn chạy lại. Tại vì sao? Tại vì như
mình nói rồi ở Docker file từ cái dòng
có thay đổi đến những dòng sau nó sẽ đều
bị chạy lại hết. Còn trước cái dòng thay
đổi là không có vấn đề gì. Thế nên ấy
nếu mà mình muốn chạy nhanh ấy mình có
thể cho này xuống cuối mà thôi mình cho
chạy lên thử cho các bạn xem trông như
thế nào nhá. Được chưa? Mình lại ra
ngoài này. Ctrl D ra ngoài được chưa?
Mình lại bui lại này. Bui lại nhá.
Cái bước form này rất là nhanh rồi tại
vì nó ở trước cái dòng thay đổi có bạn
nhìn không? Cái dòng thay đổi các bạn
nhớ không? Đây nó lại nó lại ngồi nó chạ
chạy lại này. Mặc dù vậy mình update
rồi, mình install rồi nó nó chạy lại từ
đầu coi như là mới tinh. Được chưa? Đánh
nó lại ngồi chạy lại. Mặc dù thật ra là
hai dòng này nó chả có gì mới cả đúng
không? Nếu cái chỗ này cái dòng này mình
để xuống dưới cùng thì nó sẽ chạy rất là
nhanh. Tại vì là cái dòng thay đổi nó ở
dòng ở cuối. Thế nhưng mà đây mình cho
nó nhét vào giữa này đúng không? Thì chỗ
nào sau đấy là nó sẽ đều bị chạy lại cả.
[hắng giọng]
Đ các bạn xong này. Bây giờ sau này mình
vào container nó sẽ chui ngay vào cái
thư mục này chứ nó không ở cái thư mục
root, không ở cái thư mục gốc nữa. Đ
không
[hắng giọng]
[khịt mũi]
chờ một tí nhá. Đúng. Bữa này bữa chúng
ta vừa làm rồi nhưng mà tại vì chúng ta
vừa thay đổi một cái dòng mới vào đây.
Thay đổi là là bao bồm các bạn thêm xóa
sửa. Các bạn thêm một cái dòng mới là nó
đây coi như là thay đổi rồi. Thấy không?
Ừ.
Không, nó cũng chả khác gì cả. để cho
các bạn các bạn quản lý cho nó dễ thôi.
Tại vì các bạn ở cái thư mục gốc các bạn
in ra nó ra một đống cái thư mục con ở
đấy. Sau khi bây giờ các bạn vào một cái
thư mục cụ thể thì nó chỉ tập trung và
những cái file các bạn trong trong đấy
thôi. Tí các bạn nhìn xem nhá. Tí mình
xào cái thư mục này nó nó sẽ mình làm gì
để cho nó đỡ bị nhầm lẫn cái thư mục của
hệ thống. Vậy các bạn vào các bạn thấy
là nó ở cái root là một đống cái thư mục
hệ thống nó hiện ra ở đây. Và mình vào
đây thì mình cho nó gọn.
Còn về mặt bản chất nó chả khác gì nhau.
Đây các bạn chờ thì nó lại đang export
ra.
Xong rồi. Xong rồi đúng không? Bây giờ
mình các bạn nhìn thử nhá. Xong rồi đúng
không? Bây giờ mình sẽ run này. Run nhá.
Các bạn nhìn chưa? Mình vào phát mình
vào thư mục Việt Nguyễn luôn mình xem
khu dục điện tại nhá. PWD này. Đấy thư
phục Việt Nguyễn luôn. Tháng phớ chả có
cái gì cả
đúng không? Bây giờ mình mình ra thư mục
tra này. Đây này. Các bạn nhìn thấy
chưa? Cái thư mục về Nguyễn mình đây
này. Đúng chưa? Bình thường lúc ngày
trước ấy là các bạn vào phát là các bạn
sẽ vào luôn cái thư mục gốc này nó hiện
ra một đống cái thư mục này. Nhìn nó sẽ
hơi bị loại đúng không? Còn bây giờ là
mình nhảy vào phát là mình vào luôn cái
thư mục Việt Nguyễn này. Đặt cái gì
trong này nó sẽ gọn hơn. Copy file nó
cũng vào trong này luôn nó sẽ gọn. Được
chưa?
CD này Việt Nguyễn được chưa? Trong này
chưa? Cái này nó chỉ là để cho nó gọn
thôi. Tức làm việc nhìn nó dễ đây. Trong
th việc nữa là nó không có cái gì cả. Nó
không bị nhầm lẫn cái gì, không bị không
sợ bị xóa nhầm cái gì cả. Được chưa? Thế
bây giờ cái việc tiếp theo mình phải làm
gì? Là mình phải copy.
Copy cái gì? Mình phải copy. Ví dụ các
bạn copy script Python. Các bạn copy
copy cái file dữ liệu từ máy của các bạn
vào bên trong của container đúng không?
Mình muốn chạy cái script này thì đầu
tiên mình phải có cái mình muốn chạy cái
trình huấn luyện mình phải có cái file
DBT là cái file cái file CSV này mình có
cái file Python đã đúng không? Thì copy
như nào các bạn nhìn nhá. Bây giờ mình
muốn copy này. Bây giờ ấy nếu mình thêm
dòng copy ở đây này. Nếu thêm dòng copy
ở đây ấy thì những cái dòng sau nó sẽ bị
chạy lại.
Trong khi các bạn copy ở sau cuối này nó
sẽ không ảnh hưởng gì cả. Đây copy ở đây
copy nhá. Copy này. Mình đang ở mình
đang ở thư mục là machine này. Được
chưa? Mình có cái file là
classification.py này. Được chưa?
Classification.py
đây là cái file ở máy của mình. Mình sẽ
copy nó vào bên trong container. Copy
vào đâu các bạn nhìn đây. Mặc định là nó
sẽ copy vào trong cái thư mục này. Được
chưa? Bây giờ mình sẽ có thể mình nó sẽ
copy vào trong thư mục này. Copy mình
các bạn có thể chỉ cái tên tên nó các
bạn có thể đổi tên đi. Ví dụ là trên máy
của mình tên là classification.bypby
copy xong mình sẽ đổi là ch.py. Nội dung
bên trong thì y hiệt nhau chả khác gì
cả. Khác mỗi là tên file thôi. Copy một
file nhá. Tiếp này. Copy cái file của
mình là file DavT. Dia thì mình sẽ để
nguyên. Tại vì cái này mà mình đổi nữa
thì tại vì là cái trong cái script này
nó đọc nó đọc file đồ vào mà. Bây giờ
mình mà đổi thì nó lại vào trong nó lại
đổi luôn thì cũng không ổn đúng không?
Đây
chcv
được chưa? Copy hai file này.
Và vì ấy mình thêm hai cái file này ở
cuối nên bây giờ mình bui lại rất là
nhanh. Mình ra ngoài mình bại nhá. Bui
cực kỳ nhanh luôn. Tại vì copy nó rất là
nhanh. Cài thư viện nó mới lâu chứ còn
copy những cái file này nó bé nó rất là
nhanh các bạn nhìn nhá. Đây này mình bui
nhá. Chạy cực kỳ nhanh luôn
đấy. Nhanh không? Tại vì sao? Tại copy
nó nhanh. File mình nhẹ mà. Squip thì
chỉ vài kb thôi. Còn cái file kia nó
cũng chỉ file kia nó cũng bé mà. Mấy mấy
kilb rất là nhanh. Được chưa? Mấy cái
ông ở trước này nó nằm trong kết hết
rồi. Đây này. Ông 1.6 là cái ông là cái
dòng form này nó có sẵn rồi các bạn. Có
sẵn cái docker mate này rồi. Được chưa?
Mấy ông kia toàn cas cả này đúng không?
Rất là nhanh đúng chưa? Mấy cái dòng
copy là dòng mới thôi. Xong nhá. Bây gi
mình sẽ nhảy vào bên trong này. Nhảy vào
bên trong này. Run này. Các bạn nhìn
nhá. Mình cho một cái thư mục Việt
Nguyễn đúng không? LS. Các bạn thấy
chưa? Mình có hai file chưa?
Một file này. Hai file. Được chưa?
Bây giờ mình sẽ thử kiểm tra nội dung
của hai cái file này. Muốn kiểm tra mình
phải có Vim nhưng mà máy mình chắc là
không có VM rồi. Trong Oto các bạn có
một cái công cụ để các bạn có thể đọc
nội dung của file đó là Vin nhưng mà các
bạn phải cài cơ. Đây này. App này
install này. Vin
cũng có trừ Y ở đây. Cũng có Y ở đây.
Cho nên mình sẽ thêm mình thêm mình thêm
ở đây nhá. Ví dụ bây giờ mình thêm ở cái
dòng này mình thêm là VM đi. Cái này chỉ
để mình có thể mở file thôi. Được chưa?
Thì tí mình b lại ấ nó lại ngồi nó lại
cài lại nguyên cái dòng này rất là tốn
thời gian đâ chịu thôi. Một là thêm này,
hai là mình thêm cái dòng dưới. Dòng
dưới ví dụ đây mình muốn nha anh thêm
dòng dưới này. Được chưa? Run này, app
này, install này, vin này, trừ i như này
đúng không? Thì nó sẽ không chạy lại hai
cái mấy chỗ trên nữa. Được chưa? Bây giờ
nhá, mình cài xong viim mình xem cái
file nhá. File của mình này. Vim này,
train các bạn nhìn nhá.
Đây
ở phía dưới là nội dung bên trong của
cái script của mình. Cái script mình vừa
copy đấy. Nó giống y hiệt cái file này
thôi. Nó chỉ khác nhau mỗi cái tên thôi
đúng không? Tại vì lúc với mình mình chỉ
đổi mỗi cái tên thôi mà. Còn nội dung
thì y hiển chả khác cái gì cả đúng
không? Ông này là có 55 dòng thì ông này
cũng có 55 dòng đây này. Thấy chưa? Đều
55 dòng cả giống y hiền nhau chả khác
cái gì.
Và cái file train này ấy nó là một cái
phiên bản copy của cái ông
classification này. Copy có nghĩa gì?
Tức là bây giờ các bạn thay đổi gì của
ông gốc sau khi copy rồi ấy, thay đổi gì
của cái gốc nó sẽ không ảnh hưởng đến
cái đích. Và ngược lại thay đổi của ông
này không ảnh hưởng được ông này và
ngược lại không ảnh hưởng gì nhau cả.
Được chưa?
Ví dụ nhá. Đây này. Ví dụ mình thêm đâ
mình thêm cái đoạn này nữa này. Mình
thêm nhá.
Đây mình thêm nhá.
Việt Nguyễn Ai chẳng hạn đúng không?
Mình nguyện ai này
nguyện ai này các bạn ông có khác gì đâu
đâu các bạn ông ông này thì thay đổi
nhưng mà ông trong có thay đổi gì đâu.
Tại vì đây nó chỉ là bản copy thôi. Các
bạn đem tờ một cái tờ tài liệu đi xong
ngoài hàng photocopy. Photocopy xong thì
nó thành cái file mới nguyên mà đúng
không? Được chưa? Thế
thế bây giờ mình à
mình thoát ra được chưa? Bây giờ mình
thấy là ở đây là mình đã có hai file
rồi. Mình chạy thử nhá. File phần 3 được
chưa?
Chên chpy này. Enter này. Enter này.
Đấy. Ok. Đấy. Sa chạy ok này. Thấy chưa?
Như thể lúc chúng ta như thể lúc lúc lúc
lúc chúng ta chạy trên máy của chúng ta
đấy.
Được chưa? Đấy. Này file mình mình chạy
mình dùng green search này. Đây hôm nay
có khác gì đâu đúng không? Đấy lại cũng
in ra kết quả thế này. Được chưa? Nó
cũng export ra cái file picker này. Xem
thử nhá. Đây này. Được chưa? File picker
đây này. L mình xem xích kích thước của
nó nhá.
nó cũng nặng 16 m này. Được chưa?
Đấy.
Thế đây là cái quá trình mà chúng ta
chúng ta chạy một cái đoạn script python
trong container của chúng ta. Được chưa?
Em thử thì biết. Dùng ma khi copy có bị
dính function không? Thử thì biết đúng
không?
Tại vì anh không có M để anh thử đúng
không? Không có M để anh thử. Các bạn có
thể các bạn sẽ add thêm quyền trước khi
các bạn copy nó sẽ đỡ bị lỗi hơn. Được
chưa?
Thế thôi đúng không? Đây là cái quá
trình mà các bạn
đúng các bạn tạo môi trường sau này mà
các bạn muốn chuyên mô hình này ở máy
người khác các bạn chỉn
tạo ra image xong các bạn tạo ra đầ các
bạn bui do image sau các bạn sẽ run ra
rất nhiều container xong là các bạn chạy
rồi được chưa?
Đấy đúng không? Rõ ràng máy mình là máy
Windows, mình vẫn tạo ra môi trường un
chạy bình thường rất là dễ đúng không?
Ok.
Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có cái gì chưa clear không các bạn?
Đúng không? Chúng ta chúng ta chúng ta
làm cái gì nhỉ? Chúng ta kế thừa từ một
cái docker image nào đấy. Chúng ta chỉ
ra cái thư mục làm việc của chúng ta.
Chúng ta cài cắm các thứ, chúng ta copy
các thứ đúng không? Chúng ta chạy này.
Các bạn chú ý này, hiện tại ấy là mình
cứ phải chui vào bên trong container thì
mình mới chạy đúng không? Mình phải chui
vào đây. Xong mình mới bắt đầu chạy là
Python 3. Rồi mình chên thứ này phải
mình phải ngồi chạy thủ công này. Bây
giờ ấy mình muốn là khi mình run Docker
container từ Docker image một cái là nó
sẽ chạy cái đoạn này luôn. Cho mình thì
mình làm thế nào các bạn nhìn nhá. Bây
giờ mình muốn nó r nó rôn ấy. Thì bây
giờ ở cái
file này mình thêm cái tập là cmd. Tiếp
một cái list này. Được chưa? Cậu Python
3 được chưa? Trên. Này được chưa? Mình
thêm như này nó ở đây ở dưới nhá. Mình
thoát ra khỏi này. Được chưa?
Thoát ra khỏi này. Được chưa? Bây giờ
mình thêm cái chỗ này. Thêm cái dạ này
được chưa? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
mình sẽ chạy Docker run.
run. Nhưng mà bây giờ chú ý là gì? Bây
giờ mình sẽ bỏ cái trừ it đi. Tại vì
sao? Mình không muốn chui vào bên trong
container nữa. Mình muốn chạy luôn từ
bên ngoài. Được chưa? Lúc trước ấy là
mình phải chui vào trong. Tại vì là nếu
không chui vào trong thì lúc lúc trước
là các bạn chỉ có mỗi cái dòng đầu tiên
này thôi. Các bạn mà không chui vào
trong thì nó sẽ không không hiện ra cái
gì cho các bạn xem cả. Còn bây giờ mình
lại có một đống này rồi. Nó có cài đặt
rồi, nó có copy rồi, nó có chạy lệnh rồi
đúng không? Thì v các bạn chạy docker
run ML này thôi nó sẽ chạy luôn các bạn
này.
À tình xuyên quá bạn quên mất chưa b lại
phải bại đã. Đâu b lại đã lock cơ bữa
nhá lock cơ bui này. Được chưa?
Thêm cái dòng vi này đây đúng không? Cái
dòng VM nó cái dòng vi thêm mới đúng
không? Thì cái trước cái dòng vi này thì
nó trước cái dòng cài đặt vi này thì nó
chạy giữ như cũ nhưng mà sau cái dòng
này nó sẽ cài lại. Được chưa? Bu xong
nhá. Bây giờ mình run này. Run nhớ mình
không có cái chữ IT nữa. Run này. Enter
một cái này. Đẹp chưa? Run phát nó tự
chạy luôn đúng không? Không cần phải
chui vào tự gõ thủ công nữa.
Được chưa?
Đấy xong rồi được chưa? Sau này các bạn
đem cho chạy máy đâu các bạn muốn chạy
đâu thì các bạn chạy đúng không? Các bạn
chỉ cần có docker file và các bạn có
những file cần thiết như thế các bạn có
cái file Python này, file CSV này. Thật
ra ấy cách người ta làm là sẽ là gì? Sau
khi các bạn tạo xong cái image này rồi
ấy, người ta sẽ các bạn sẽ đẩy lại lên
locker hub.
Các bạn sẽ các bạn sẽ đẩy lại lên đây
đúng không? Các bạn sẽ đẩy đ tức các bạn
phải login vào. Các bạn phải login vào
các bạn sẽ được đẩy log. Đây ví dụ mình
à
x in nh x các bạn.
Đây các bạn sẽ phải để đăng nhập vào.
Đó thì các bạn sẽ
các bạn sẽ p cái docker giống kiểu các
bạn dùng các bạn giống kiểu các bạn dùng
các bạn dùng dùng dùng dùng git này
thôi. Đây này đây là những cái từ ngày
xưa mình làm mà từ lâu lắm rồi. Thả mình
ngày xưa lâu lắm thô mình xong mình đẩy
lại các bạn từ 8 9 năm các thứ tại vì
bây giờ mình chia sẻ mình cũng không
dùng qua cái này nữa. Dùng qua nền tảng
khác được chưa? Mình chia sẻ rất là lâu
rồi. Đấy ngày xưa mình đ up up up lên
này. Đấy được chưa? Tên tài khoản mình
tên cái docker image đấy. Được chưa các
bạn? Đẩy đến đây xong cái máy nào mà cần
ấy người ta chuyển phi
bản thân những cái doer image này người
ta lên đây là nó cũng tương tự như vậy
thôi đúng không? Khi các bạn đẩy lên như
trong như này rồi ấy khi các bạn bui ra
cái docker image này rồi ấy thì có nghĩa
là gì? Có nghĩa là mấy cái file Python
với cả file dữ liệu này nó nằm trong
docker image sẵn rồi. Các bạn tạo ra
container là container nào họ có sẵn này
rồi các bạn không cần phải lo cái nguồn
nữa. Được chưa? đấy là cái ưu điểm chúng
ta dùng doer image. Tất nhiên locker
image này người ta cũng thể người ta sẽ
giới hạn quyền truy cập. Tức là có những
cái public là ai cũng dùng được. Có
những cái là private là tức là phải có
phải có cái phải có cái chỉ dẫn về thì
các bạn thì các bạn mới dùng được. Được
chưa? Nhưng mà đây là cách tổng quát để
các bạn dùng Docker.
Được chưa? Cài cài một lần chạy ở đâu
cũng được. Cái máy đí các bạn chạy ấ nó
dùng Windows hay là Mac hay là nó dùng
nó muốn dùng cái hệ điều hành gì thì nó
dùng. Nhưng các bạn vẫn chạy được bình
thường và các bạn sẽ chạy được đúng cái
hệ điều hành mà các bạn mong muốn. Đ cái
hệ đành đây này. Được chưa?
Ok. Có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Rồi các bạn. Các bạn ơi. Ờ cách đấy mấy
tuần thì có một cái buổi mình dạy các
bạn mới bị thiếu một tiếng đúng không?
Đáng nhẽ cái buổi hôm nay, đáng nhẽ buổi
hôm nay nó là buổi cuối rồi thì chúng ta
học 17 buổi mà đúng không? Nhưng mà cái
buổi đấy nó thiếu một tiếng. Hôm nay
chắc là mình cũng phải xin phép các bạn
mình các bạn cho mình xin buổi này hôm
nay chúng ta nghỉ sớm một chút. Chúng
hôm nay chúng ta chỉ học một tiếng thôi.
Thì hai buổi đều thiếm một tiếng thì thứ
bảy tuần sau chúng ta sẽ học hai tiếng
nhá. Là cái buổi chúng ta sẽ
là buổi số 18 đấy đúng không? Bình
thường chúng ta chỉ có 17 buổi thôi
nhưng mà tại vì chúng ta có hai buổi
chúng ta đều thiếm một tiếng cả. Buổi 18
chúng ta sẽ học đủ hai tiếng. Buổi lần
sau thì mình sẽ chia sẻ bạn một vài
những cái ứng dụng hay nữa về machining.
Cái thứ mà nó sẽ nó sẽ hơi ngoài phạm vi
của khóa này nhưng mà nó rất là thú vị.
Cái thứ nhất. Thứ hai nữa là cái buổi
sau thứ nhất chúng ta sẽ tổng kết kiến
thức của cả khóa và mình sẽ chia sẻ các
bạn những cái treit, những cái những cái
tài liệu tổng hợp. Tại vì cái slide của
cái khóa này ấy nó dài đến mấy trăm
trang. Nó sẽ phù hợp với những bạn mà
học lần đầu các bạn chưa biết cái gì về
machin cả. Học lần đầu các bạn sẽ ok.
Nhưng mà sau khi mà các bạn ôn kiến
thức, ví dụ các bạn đi phỏng vấn chẳng
hạn mà các bạn ngồi nhìn slide của mình
nó sẽ không không phù hợp. Slide mình
chỉ hợp để học lần đầu thôi, không hợp
để tổng kết kiến thức. Tổng kết kiến
thức các bạn sẽ cần những cái tài liệu
nó nhỏ gọn, nó tổng quát vài trang thôi
nhưng mà nó phải cover hết các kiến
thức. Thì buổi tới mình sẽ chia sẻ bạn
những cái tài liệu như vậy. Đồng thời
mình sẽ chia sẻ bạn một vài những cái
nguồn cả bằng à cả bằng tiếng Việt và
tiếng Anh để sau này nếu các bạn có muốn
học lên cao mà các bạn không học mình,
các bạn muốn tự học. Tại vì thật ra cái
khóa này nó cũng trang bị cho bạn những
kiến thức cơ bản rồi. Cơ bản rất là ok.
Rồi sa các bạn muốn tự học lên, các bạn
học lên về conservation, về NLP cái gì
đấy thì mình sẽ chia sẻ bạn những cái
nguồn để các bạn có thể học được. Có một
vài quyển sách bằng tiếng Việt, có một
vài nguồn bằng tiếng Anh khá là ok và
đấy là được những cái nguồn mà bản thân
mình đều đã mình đã hoặc là mình đã trải
nghiệm hoặc là mình đã có được cái
review từ những người rất là uy tín rồi
sẽ chia sẻ bạn những cái tài liệu đấy
nhá. Tất cả đều này những cái về khoa
học đều những khoa học mình đã từng trải
nghiệm rồi. Chính mình ngày xưa khi mình
học ở T Mic ngày xưa mình học ở T Mic ấ
tài liệu của trường mình thì chán lắm.
Cái slide của trường mình nó rất là
chán, rất là khó hiểu luôn.
Buổi sau mình sẽ chia sẻ các bạn. Cho
các bạn nhìn xem cái tài liệu của mình
nó chán đến mức nào nên mình phải tìm
cái tài liệu ngoài nó học nó dễ vào hơn.
Được chưa?
Ok. Cả kinh nghiệm xin việc làm việc
nữa. Ok. Nhất trí. Buổi sau là buổi cuối
nó rất là mở. Các bạn thích hỏi cái gì
mình sẽ hỏi các bạn ở đây nhá.
Ok.
Đúng rồi. Tại vì sao? Học trên trường nó
theo hướng Hàn Lâm. Hàn Lâm thì mình
phải khó hiểu là chắc chắn rồi. Đúng
không? Đúng rồi. Học trên trường đại học
là theo cái chương trình chính Q nó Hàn
Lâm. Hàn Lâm chắc chắn là phải khó hiểu
rồi. Hàn Lâm không thể dễ hiểu được.
Cloud thì gần như con nào chả chạy unu.
Nhưng mà các bạn muốn dùng ví dụ các bạn
muốn dùng ví dụ nh ví dụ em muốn dùng
GPU nhá. Đúng không? Em muốn dùng GPU
đúng không? Thì ví dụ như là bọn Google
collab có cái nó có nó có cái gói cho
sinh viên nhưng mà nếu mà em không phải
sinh viên ấy mà em muốn dùng thì em có
thể lên cg kg thì một tuần nó cho dùng
free 30 tiếng đấy. Đây này kg mình có
tài khoản nhá. Đây mình có cái phần đây
này. Một tuần cho 30 tiếng này. Được
chưa? Cái này ra đem phải cho lớp de
deep learning lớp mình không động gì đến
GPU cả. Các bạn có notebook nhá.
Notebook nhá. Đúng không? Tạo ra
notebook này đúng không? Bình thường nó
chạy nó chạy nó sẽ không setting này
đúng không? Nó sẽ không dùng cái gì đâu.
Các bạn thể chạy con setting khác này.
Mình dùng P100 nhá. Hoặc mình dùng hai
con T4 nhá. Được chưa? Con T4 này. Tol
này. Được chưa? Chúng ta sẽ reset lại.
Reset chưa ấy nhỉ?
T nhá. Được chưa? Mình chạy thử này.
Chờ thì chạy lại nhá.
Đây mình dùng hai con T4 nhá. Được chưa?
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Đây này. Thấy chưa? Mỗi con 16 GB thoải
mái. Mỗi tuần chỉ có 3 tiếng thôi. À mỗi
con chỉ dùng 30 tiếng thôi. Các bạn cứ
làm năm cái tài khoản dùng cả tuần chưa?
Nó dùng umun đấy. Dùng Umuntu đấy. Chưa.
Thế thôi.
Ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Đấy các bạn nhá. Thứ bảy đ sau chúng ta
học về cuối nhá. Học full 2 tiếng được
chưa? À nốt một vài cái thứ nữa về
machining. Chúng ta tổng kết chúng ta
nói về những cái tài liệu giúp tổng kết
kiến thức những cái khoa học mà các bạn
có thể học online free đúng không? Không
nhất thế bài học khóa học của mình. Được
chưa?
Ok cảm ơn mọi người nha. Chúc các bạn
tối vui vẻ. Chúc các bạn tuần mới học
tập và làm việc hiệu quả. Bây giờ sau
chúng ta lại gặp nhau nhá.
Hi mọi người nha.